Einst war hier der Todesstreifen zwischen
Ost- und Westdeutschland.
Heute ist es eines der größten deutschen
Naturschutzgebiete:
der Nationalpark Harz, entstanden vor 30
Jahren.
Genauso lang kümmert sich Biologe Gunter
Karste darum,
dass hier wieder zusammenwächst, was
zusammengehörte.
Das Besondere am Nationalpark ist
tatsächlich die Tatsache,
dass man auf 24.730 Hektar bereit ist,
der Natur ihren eigenen Spielraum zu lassen.
Dass man also darauf verzichtet im Prinzip,
die Fläche zu nutzen,
also in Richtung klassische Holzwirtschaft,
und dass man also tatsächlich der Natur die
Chance gibt, zu zeigen,
wozu sie in der Lage ist.
Damals mussten die Frauen und Männer
des Nationalparks bei Null anfangen,
wie hier am ehemaligen Todesstreifen.
1989 patrouillierten hier DDR-Grenzschützer.
Eine hunderte Meter breite Schneise sollte
jede Flucht aus der DDR verhindern.
Die Grenzanlagen: ein fast unüberwindliches
Bollwerk aus Stacheldraht und Beton.
Drei Jahrzehnte später hat die Natur
hier ganze Arbeit geleistet.
Die Birke hat hier also tatsächlich das
Rennen gemacht.
Dieser Streifen wurde mit Herbiziden,
Pestiziden behandelt, und hier war eigentlich
kein Leben möglich,
und man sieht jetzt hier,
hier ist in den letzten 30 Jahren tatsächlich
also viel passiert.
Doch nicht nur Pflanzen, auch Tiere erobern
sich im Harz
ihre angestammten Lebensräume zurück.
Mit solchen versteckten Kameras wird auch
der neue wilde Bewohner des Nationalparks
dokumentiert: der Luchs.
Vor gut 200 Jahren
war die Raubkatze ausgestorben,
jetzt sind hier weit mehr als 100 Exemplare
wieder heimisch.
Der Luchs ist ’n alter Harzer,
der vom Menschen ausgerottet wurde und der
es sich verdient hat,
also hier auch wieder im Harz unterwegs zu
sein.
Und vor dem Hintergrund war das also
das große Experiment, was der Nationalpark
1994/95 gestartet hat,
diesen Luchs wieder einzubürgern.
Erfolgsgeschichten, hinter denen harte Arbeit
steckt.
Tausende Stunden war der Biologe in den
Wäldern unterwegs,
zehntausende Notizen, wie sich die Natur die
Grenzregion zurückerobert.
Und doch steht die größte Herausforderung
für die Frauen und Männer des Nationalparks
noch bevor: tote Bäume, soweit das Auge
reicht.
Früher waren hier riesige Fichtenkulturen.
Trockenheit und steigende Temperaturen
haben die Bäume geschwächt,
den Rest besorgte der Borkenkäfer.
Immer häufiger muss Karste deshalb bei
seinen Touren Aufklärungsarbeit leisten.
Das ist richtig traurig, wenn man hier
hochgeht.
Aber man muss eben auch wissen:
Gucken Sie, wenn Sie hier in diese Fläche
schauen – da, wo die Fichten
also beispielsweise sich schon vor längerer
Zeit verabschiedet haben,
da entsteht neues Leben.
Eine Mammutaufgabe,
bei der die Behörden aus Ost und West enger
denn je zusammenarbeiten –
undenkbar ohne die deutsche Einheit.
Streiten wollen wir uns trotzdem mal, weil ...
sonst fehlt uns ja die Grundlage
auch für Neues, ne?
Also, die Diskussion brauchen wir trotzdem.
Also, dann hat man keinen Fortschritt, wenn’s
alles nur ’n Einheitsbrei ist.
Die Fahrt geht weiter
zum höchsten Punkt des Nationalparks:
dem Brocken.
Auf dem Weg liegt dieses ehemalige Hotel.
Gunter Karste geht mit uns hinein.
Vor gut 30 Jahren, erzählt er, logierten hier
verdiente Mitarbeiter
des DDR-Staatssicherheitsdienstes.
Sie machten Urlaub von ihrer Aufgabe, das
eigene Volk zu bespitzeln.
Das war schon in einer gewisser Weise
Bonzentum,
und genau die waren hier drin.
In diesen Räumen scheint die Zeit stehen
geblieben zu sein.
Beim ehemaligen DDR-Bürger Karste sorgt
sie noch heute für bittere Erinnerungen.
Als Student im sechsten Semester
hatte ich also auch ein Zusammentreffen
mit der Staatssicherheit.
Die wollte, dass ich meinen
Studienfreund bespitzele und [ich] hab das
abgelehnt –
wohlwissend, dass das für mich hätte
Konsequenzen haben können.
Aber damit hat man gelebt, das war unser
Zuhause hier.
Der Harz ist unser Zuhause. Nee, das geht
jetzt nicht.
Dann ist das Ziel erreicht.
Auf über 1100 Metern: der Brocken.
Einst hermetisch abgeriegelt horchten
Sowjets
und der DDR-Geheimdienst mit diesen
Anlagen tief hinein in den Westen.
Jetzt wächst und gedeiht gleich nebenan der
ganze Stolz des Botanikers Karste:
ein Garten mit hunderten Pflanzen.
Das heißt, der Brocken hat also
ein Stückchen seiner Ursprünglichkeit,
seiner Naturnähe im Zuge der Zeit
in den letzten 30 Jahren zurückerhalten.
Und vor dem Hintergrund sind wir wirklich
glücklich.
Und die Aufgabe, sagt Gunter Karste, gehe
weiter.
So lange, bis eines Tages endgültig wieder
das zusammengewachsen ist,
was zusammengehört.